tu as pris le chemin classique un stage
au parlement un stage à la commission
assistant parlementaire auprès d'une
députée commission environnement santé
publique et sécurité alimentaire
il a toujours rêvé d'être lobbyistes
encore un nom auprès de sa députée puis
il défendra notamment les pesticides
avec europe connexion alexandra badea
écrit sur les enjeux de santé publique
que mathieu roy l'étincelle manière de
parler d'un fait de société politique et
économique très important aujourd'hui et
alexandra badea le fait d'une manière
dramaturgique très intéressante et très
forte un point de vue théâtre c'est
important aussi que le théâtre s'empare
de ces phénomènes de société pour
raconter des histoires et évidemment
faire prendre conscience aux spectateurs
de l'urgence de changer nos modes de
production et de fonctionnement
notamment dans notre consommation
alimentaire de tous les jours 10 micro
saynète jouée en français et en mandarin
des saynètes qui s'enchaînent sans répit
comme le fournissement du parlement
européen
le spectateur vit avec les personnages
c'est un rapport de spectateurs immersif
où on va mettre les spectateurs sur le
plateau du théâtre dans un rapport
quadri frontale c'est à dire qu'ils sont
de part et d'autre des quatre faces de
la scénographie et les spectateurs vont
pouvoir regarder ce qui va se passer
sous leurs yeux en étant assez proche
des comédiens à la fois par le casque
audio qui vont mettre sur leurs oreilles
et puis aussi par la proximité physique
parce que les acteurs sont à 50 cm à 1 m
un casque pour entendre les pensées du
lobbyisme un jeune homme qui voit petit
à petit le piège se refermer sur lui une
métaphore du burn out europe connexion
est une pièce fictive qui prend parfois
des aspects documentaires
tu aurais pu mettre ton intelligence
dans des causes plus nobles
tu aurais pu faire de la recherche
tu aurais pu écrire des bouquins tu
aurais pu éclairer le monde
mais tout ça ne t'aurais pas donné tout
ce pouvoir